so you're looking to pick up Dark Souls  3 on xbox one but you're kind of bums  you never got to play the original well  don't worry because right now you can  get dark souls for free with your  digital pre-order microsoft says this  deal is only for a limited time but you  can pre-order the standard or deluxe  edition of Dark Souls 3 and get yourself  a code within 7 to 10 days we're not  sure if the artorias of the abyss dlc is  included but if you were looking to warm  up in Lordran before jumping into the  third game now's your chance Dark Souls  3 hits xbox one ps4 and PC on April  twelfth and director hit Atacama ezaki  claims that this will be the end of the  saga when the game launches we'll have  plenty to show you at gamespot in the  meantime I've got a new game plus I need  to finish  you